as a millennial deciding to quit social
media when I was still in college was
definitely a decision that was difficult
to make but at the same time made me
kind of The Loner the odd one out
because it seemed like most of my
colleagues or if not all of them had
some form of social media and websites
like Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
were gaining popularity very quickly I
could certainly have asked the adults in
my life hey what's it like to not have
social media but for them it was the
norm in my stage in life it was the norm
to have it and so I wish that at that
point in time I could have had somebody
to talk to about it that could relate to
me but at that point pretty much
everybody that I talked to thought that
I was so weird because I didn't want to
have social media so I thought this
would be the perfect opportunity to
share your stories because I have
received many comments from you guys as
well as emails talking about the
struggles that you've had how social
media has caused anxiety or difficulty
in your relationships however I've also
had success stories from you guys so I
thought it would be fun to share your
stories as an encouragement if you are
deciding to quit social media or maybe
you just want to take a break for a
little while if you're new hey my name
is yesi on this channel we talk about
minimalism and how to live life more
fully with less but since many of you
have demonstrated an interest in
specifically talking about digital
minimalism I have an entire playlist
devoted to that topic and how to have a
better balance with your technology
because sometimes it's not about
eliminating it all together so you can
check that out if you need more help or
more encouragement but with that being
said let's get started AJC says I
deleted my social media not seeing reels
tick tocks have improved My overall
health too much negativity online and
it's ultimately a waste of time oh my
goodness when you're mentioning the
negativity online I think it's not
necessarily even just social media it
can be the news or it can be other forms
of media that we might be consuming but
I think that when we're constantly
hearing negative things it changes our
perspective on the world on the people
around us and it can affect the way that
we treat other people so if we can just
take a step back and maybe cut some of
that negativity out where we can I think
it can do wonders for improving our
mindset overall Ruben Garcia says I left
Facebook and Twitter two years ago and I
don't think of going back I only use
Instagram but don't post on it every day
ever since I left most of social media I
will say life has been good like not
worrying about what people are posting
or someone posting about their breakup
and divorce Etc now I can just focus on
my life work and watch movies and TV
shows without distractions life without
social media is better
there are several points that I want to
make here because I think when you're
specifically talking about breakups and
divorce just like I had mentioned before
the more that we hear all these stories
about relationships going sour the more
anxiety or fear it might cause within us
but if we are surrounded by people that
are positive that have strong healthy
relationships it's much more likely that
we are going to perceive relationships
in that manner if you've heard the
saying you are the average of The Five
People You spend the most time with well
how many people are you hearing their
stories online and what kinds of stories
are they telling is it positive or
negative in nature and how is it going
to affect you overall I also like that
you mentioned I don't post on it every
day but you still have it see sometimes
I don't think that we need to completely
eliminate it like don't get me wrong I'm
not like a social media hater obviously
this YouTube channel is what I started
after having quit social media it's
still a form of social media I think
that the important thing is whatever
form you have is It ultimately helping
you live a better life and live your
purpose whatever that my might be or is
it something that's hindering you that's
causing more anxiety or more problems or
worry so just ultimately doing it with
intention Phil T says after 15 years of
obsessive use I closed my accounts two
weeks ago best decision ever so much
more chilled out no algorithms targeting
me with triggering articles no having to
witness just how vile people can be to
each other my plan was for a year the
impact of these first two weeks suggests
that year will just become my new normal
and I won't ever return social media
should be a great thing but like all
things humans touch it has become toxic
there are several things that I want to
talk about here I definitely think that
for me after some time it does become a
new normal it's like I can't even
remember that point in my life when I
basically obsessed over wanting to see
what other people were doing and what
other people were wearing and comparing
myself to all these Instagram reels so
yes I think that after time it does get
better I think it's easier so if you're
just starting off and you definitely
want to quit and not just cut back hang
in there it gets easier but I want to
touch on this very important last part
that you mentioned like all things
humans touch it has become toxic
see I think that this is important to
talk about because I am somebody that
wants to desperately believe and that we
have dignity we have value and that
there is good in humanity I don't want
to believe that all things human touch
go sour go toxic because if I think that
way then I'm being part of the problem
I'm not being part of the solution if we
are worrying about what will happen with
the generation rather than being the
change that we want to see and
encouraging other people to pursue
positive things then we are a part of
the problem and we have to try to be
that positive change that we want to see
you know do like Gandhi be the change
that you want to see in the world but
it's a lot easier said than done this
next one is short Justin says using
Facebook made me feel mentally ill I
think this is huge to talk about because
there is a huge correlation between
social anxiety and social media usage I
had been diagnosed with social anxiety
and at that point in my life I could see
a friend that I was so used to talking
to at school but if I saw them in the
grocery store just passing by I would
immediately turn the other way because
my mind would immediately start thinking
what do I say what do I how do I start a
conversation how do I put my hands like
what do I do with my body language and
immediately my hands would start
sweating my heart would start racing I
would I would start sweating pretty much
everywhere I mean it was fully social
anxiety and I share more about how I
overcame social anxiety in a separate
video in case you want to see that but I
definitely think that it can be related
with social anxiety or just anxiety in
general it's also important to note that
when you're anxious or when you're
stressed it increases cortisol levels in
your body which is linked to
inflammation and inflammation is linked
to pretty much every disease out there
not only does Stress and Anxiety make
you feel mentally ill but it can cause
you to be physically ill as well babeli
says for those who read this quit social
media and you'll not be interested or
addicted to your phone I want to talk
about this because a lot of people talk
about when you quit social media then
you have your phone and it's just
replacing one addiction with another
that can definitely be the case I will
not negate that it can be easy to
replace one addiction with another
however when you focus first on
intention and the reason why you want to
stop all to begin with is it to improve
your life is it to focus on your hobbies
as if to focus on serving other people
spending more time with your family or
your friends what is your reason why
then it changes how you use all your
technology because my reason was solid
and I knew my values and what I wanted
with my life and how I wanted to improve
it became a lot easier for me to then
say I don't want to spend two hours
watching funny cat videos because I
value my time so much more so if this is
a difficult situation for you and you're
having the struggle between now you're
addicted to your phone I highly
recommend you consider and just sit down
with yourself and be honest and say why
do I want this why is this important for
me
what do I want out of this change asking
these questions will get you a long way
Jack Carraway says I'm active duty and I
got rid of all my social media Sans
messenger in case I have Wi-Fi but poor
reception which is increasingly common
right before I left home for basically
two years here's what happened since one
I stopped going through long bouts of
depression two I stopped hearing about
being popular or what others think of me
three I stopped comparing myself to
others four the toxic people I did know
back home are fading from my memory or I
just stopped caring about them entirely
and five I've become a lot more goal
oriented how awesome that you
experienced all of these different
benefits I know for me the comparison
was definitely a huge trap when I had
Facebook and Instagram I would
constantly see images or pictures of
other people living their perfect lives
doing their perfect things and I
compared myself to that Ideal Image as
though I should somehow live their ideal
life but when that was gone I ultimately
had to ask myself well what is my ideal
life what do I want in life and how do I
want to live it it was no longer focused
on trying to do what everybody else was
doing rather trying to do what I am
called to do and pursuing my purpose
Paris student says after my mother
passed away I realized how precious time
is unfortunately I was a teen when
social media became popular and came out
I'm 21. before quitting social media I
was always saying sorry I can't make it
because I'm busy I wasn't busy I was
just constantly on social media since
quitting social media I realized
everyone who has my number is people I
already talked to under 50. I had
hundreds of friends on social media I
don't miss it time is precious since
leaving social media I'm no longer stuck
in my house scrolling I'm always out and
about visiting friends and family as
well as my work oh my goodness I wish I
could give you a hug right now I work as
a hospice nurse my job is working with
people that are at end stages of life
and because of that it has changed my
perception on the value of our time and
the value of my life and just wanting to
just savor every moment of it and I
think when we are mindlessly scrolling
and not realizing what we're actually
spending our time on we we are missing
out on precious moments that we will
never get back I assure you that my
patients are not wishing that they had
spent more time scrolling they're
wishing that they had spent more time
with their family they're wishing that
they had taken the risk that they were
afraid to take so ask yourself what your
priorities are and if you feel like
you're suffocated in the busy and the
rat race and just running between one
thing and another and that you don't
have time for all the things that you
have to do maybe just cutting back some
time on your social media or your
endless scrolling might go a long way to
just reduce all of that noise and give
you more peace and calm during your day
and lastly Stevie dub says a year clean
from social media and except YouTube
which I don't consider social media and
I feel so much better mentally it's like
a weight lifted off my shoulders it's
such a toxic Place constantly comparing
yourself to others not living in the
moment not seeing all the negative News
Daily
Etc it's sad I see people walking
looking at their phone people can't even
go for walks without having to scroll
instead of enjoying fresh air and mother
nature such a pathetic generation we
live in it's worse than drugs people are
like zombies I'm angry I had to be born
in this era and I wish I was in the 80s
when people had fun and enjoyed life and
partied and went clubbing Etc people
from that era are so lucky I think it's
amazing that you have such a value for
spending time outside and nature and
just enjoying the simple things in life
but I think it's also important to look
at it from an aspect of compassion just
like you mentioned a lot of us are
becoming zombies but it is addictive it
is like a drug that dopamine Spike can
become addictive maybe just maybe if we
come at it from an angle of compassion
we might catch more flies with honey
than with vinegar although I don't
really understand that saying I don't
know why anybody would want to catch
flies if somebody can fill me in in the
comments below why that is even a saying
and why would you want to catch flies I
would love it if you could enlighten me
I want to thank you for not only sharing
your success stories but also sharing
your vulnerabilities and sharing those
struggles that you have faced because by
doing this we can encourage each other
and develop a community of like-minded
people that want to live life more fully
whether that be with less technology
less stuff less things on our schedule
and having encouragement from other
people and just hearing other people
share how it helps them or how it's
improved their lives can be a huge
motivator so thank you so much and it's
also super encouraging to me as well it
means a lot to me so I thank you so much
for watching I thank you so much for
sharing your stories and emails and if
you have any suggestions of further
videos that you want to see please share
Below in the comments if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up and
subscribe so you won't miss when I post
a new video or share it with a friend in
case they might need it as well until
next time bye for now